thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
when The Rescuers were on their way
there were so many obstacles in the way
obstacles in the way to the building
locks on the door the neighborhood was
blocked and when the workers came when
the police came they could not get into
the building immediately they had to get
around all these obstacles and barriers
in their way by the time they arrived
people were already dead
easier
[Music]
surprising in the sense that compared to
the protests in China in 1990s and 2000s
and we see a lot of protests but many of
these protests with string
themselves by targeting local officials
and trying to express their loyalty to
the center but this time you see slogans
uh chanting like Xi Jinping step downs
and and even some call for freedom of
expression
[Music]
[Music]
for now that definitely the government
will will resort to this kind of a harsh
Crackdown and measures and then it is an
imaginable that they will try to resolve
the issue by backing down changing the
policy it's not the Xi Jinping style and
and it's not going to do any good for
them anyway
[Music]
don't move